Mark: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to the Bottle Flip Challenge.
We've got a bunch of water bottles and we've got a bunch of friends.
*laughter*
Wade: Don't say it so happily.
*more laughter*
Mark: So, what we're going to be doing is we're going to be taking turns flipping this water bottle on this thing.
It's going to be an elimination-style round for the first one.
Originally, we're just going to do a very basic- *thunk as the bottle hits the table* -flip, and if you get it, you're out and you're safe.
If you don't get it, you have to keep flipping down the line until you get to the last person.
And the last person not able to get the flip gets shot with arrows.
Bob: In the face.
Mark: Preferrably not.
Bob: Or not. *laughter*
The opposite of that.
Mark: The opposite of-
Bob: Not in the face.
Mark: Everywhere but the face.
Bob: In the dick.
Mark: In the dick.
Ethan: Right in the ass.
Mark: That's not the dick.
They're getting shot with an arrow.
To recap that- *begins imbibing air
*grunts through disfigured lips*
Ethan: Fucking hate it when you do that.
*responds with caveman jargon*
Ethan: I hate it so much.
Mark: Why?
Ethan: Because I have to make it funny.
*intense laughter*
Mark: So who's going to go first?
Giant five-way rock, paper, scissors?
Ethan: Yeah.
Bob: Sure.
All: Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Tyler: Woah, we're out.
Mark: So now you three.
Bob, Wade, and Ethan: Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Ethan: Ah, ha.
Tyler: It's a three-way tie.
Mark: That's a tie.
Bob: Wait. no. One, two, three, you guys play off for four and five.
Mark: Damn it. I'm last. [Ethan: You're last.] Alright. So, I'm first?
So, I'm pretty sure I'm safe. These guys aren't very good.
Tyler: Line up!
Wade: Am I okay to go now?
Tyler: Uh, yeah, go.
Wade: Nope.
Ethan: Okay.
Bob: Oh, shit.
Bob: Ah!
Wade: I was hoping I could make it on the first try though.
Bob: That would be awesome.
Tyler: Yeah!
Wooh!
*sound of Tyler and Ethan high-fiving
Mark: Ahhhhh.
Wade: OHHHHH.
Bob: Aw, shit.
*laughter in background*
Bob: Aw, damn it.
Ethan: Who's it going to be? Who's going to get the punishment?
Mark: Awww. All of you cheated.
Bob: Jesus Christ.
*laughter*
Mark: No, you go ahead, go ahead.
Bob: Aw.
*resounding ooh*
Bob: Fuck.
Mark: Ordinarily, I'm better at this than-
Wade: You're so good this round.
*burst of laughter*
All: OHHHHHH!
Wade: First try!
Mark: Okay, so I lost.
I get shot in the dick.
Bob: In the dick.
Mark: In the dick. [Ethan: Penis.]
Wade: In the ass part.
Tyler: It's a hard target.
Mark: In the dick
*laughter*
All: OHHHHHH!
Mark: Alright.
Mark: I lost so... here we go!
*whistling sound as the arrows fly towards Mark while he screams in terror*
Mark: Oh, geez!
Wade: What was that?
Mark: This is so scary!
Bob: Quit flinching. Ready, load.
Mark: How can I stop flinching? [Bob: Aim.] I'd have to close my eyes.
Ethan: Wait, I'm not ready!
*shots fire towards Mark*
Tyler: I keep missing!!
Mark: What are you aiming for?
Ethan: I don't know! [Mark: What are you aiming for?] I was trying to hit you in the chest.
Bob: Alright, load. FIRE!
Mark: Oh, that one hurt. Whoever that one was....
Mark: Who was this? Was that you?
Bob: I hit you right in the sternum.
Ethan: I wasn't even ready.
Wade: That was Bob.
Mark: You hit me right- oh, that one hurt.
Hit me right on the- right on the bone.
Mark: So, we're going to be a little further away. We've got a line in the sand here.
Giant five-way rock, paper, scissors.
Wade: Why don't we just go in reverse order of "who lost last time goes first?"
Tyler: *unintelligible*
Wade: Yeah, like Tyler said.
Mark: Alright okay y'know alright.
Wade: So, it's gonna be you, then Bob, then me, then Tyler, then Ethan.
*agreeing sounds*
*intense music plays as they try to flip the bottle*
*Mark moans*
Uuuh....
Everyone: Whoa!
"One eternity later..."
Bob: *yells in anguish* GOD DAMNIT!
*Wade grunts*
*In the background off camera* OKAY.
Ethan: FUCK!
It's so CLOSE! Every time!
*exhales*
*exhale 4x combo*
Mark: Granny style. It's like Granny style, y'know?
Granny shot?
Wade: My Granny never did that.
Mark: Your Granny never did this?
Wade: No.
My...Granny...did!
*Everyone laughs at Mark's failure*
Mark: Yeah, we suck. So we decided that Tyler is-
better than us, in every way.
EVERY way.
Every single way, he's better than us. He's proven this by this one challenge.
Tyler: GIVE ME MY HAT!
Mark: He is better than us in every way so he's going to shoot-
all of us with arrows, if he can.
Ethan: I'm SO AFRAID.
Wade: I KNOW.
Bob: Just cover the- Just cover the back of your head, you'll be fine.
Wade: Tyler's the scariest one!
Mark: Ow, mah butt.
What a wimpy shot!
Wade: There's a fly in my ear.
Ethan: No, don't say THAT!
Mark: What a pathetic baby shot!
Bob: You suck.
Wade: Tyler, I always respected you as a person.
Mark: What a pissant little- Do you even have muscles?
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: Oh, my god.
Ethan: Don't make him angry! [Tyler: you really want it, Mark?]
Mark: Do you even..have like..balls?
Bob: Why are you doing this to us?
All: WHOAHHHHHH!
*laughter*
Wade: WHAT WAS THAT???
*faint terrified scream*
Tyler: That was a perfect...
Ethan: I just wanna go home!
Tyler: That was on purpose!
Ethan: Why did I move here!
Mark: Where did it go??
Tyler: It came back to me.
Mark: You don't get to shoot it again!
Tyler: I'm not going to!
Mark: W-what a bitch, can't even hit us...
*screams of fear and pain*
*Ethan screams in fear*
Mark: How did you flip that bottle if you can't hit anything?
Wade: I don't know....
Bob: He can't - *screams* FUCKING SHIT.
Bob: Stop making him mad!
Mark: Why?
[Ethan: You're messing with the bull!]
Mark: It's not like he's gonna -
OOOH
Mark: Oh man.
Mark: Hit me full force! Come on!
Tyler: Okay.
Mark: Do it.
*laughter mixed with Ethans screams*
Get over there!
*Mark grunts in pain*
Mark: Right on mah spine!
*laughter*
Tyler: I got four more shots!
Ethan and Wade: FOUR MORE SHOTS?!
*Laughter mixed with "ooooh myy gawwd" and "oooh" [Mark: I feel like I've been singled out for an unfair reason.]
Ethan: Ooh...ohw, ohw... that just, like, grazed me!
Wade: We're all gonna die...OH THAT WAS RIGHT ON THE ASS.
Mark: One more? One more.
Wade: That scared me more than it hurt in all honesty.
Mark: Do full power Tyler.
Everyone else: NOOO NO NO NO!!!!!!
Ethan: *softly* Okay, he's done...
Tyler: I did full power to your calf. *giggles*
Ethan: Did you? *softly* Okay...
Tyler: Not full power, like, 3/4.
Wade: I was very lucky, that was my hip.
Tyler: That one wasn't even full!
Mark: That was right on my spine.
Mark: Wait, hang on. OOOH Jesus OK. Well Bob's going for this. I wanted, uhhhh..
*everyone chanting "CHUG CHUG CHUG"*
Bob: Aaah...
*laughter*
[Mark: We're, we're in a drought.]
Mark: OK so now we're doing the big bottle flip. Bob is currently working on the bottle.
*Bob coughs*
Mark: Alright. So we got our big bottle ready. I drank that whole thing. See that? Did you see that? Whoo.
Mark: It was full, now it's empty.
Mark: Anyway...
Rock, paper, scissors, SHOOT.
Mark: Welp, I'm a loser.
*laughter* [Mark: Alright then.]
Bob: YEAAAH.
Tyler: OOOH. Bob wins, Bob gets to go first.
Tyler: Damn it!
Ethan: YAAAH.
Mark: You got this Bob.
Bob: OOOHW.
Ethan: HO!
Ethan: Hehehehe...just like last time!
Tyler: Whoo!
Mark: Whoopsies.
Tyler and Ethan: NICE.
*disappointed "oooh"*
Mark: Get more spin.
Wade: I know.
*OOOOOOOH!* [Mark: We gotta fuck it down.]
Mark: ALRIGHT, now we gonna FUCK HIM UP.
Mark: So get on over.
*various "Bend Over Wade"s*
Tyler: Alright Wade, you ready?
Wade: NO!
Wade: I'm here because I was invited to LA to-
Wade: ARGHH THIS! ARGHH!
(laughter)
Wade: You speared them in the DICK! Why?
Wade: I was- ARGHH!!!
STOP!! ARGHH!
Mark: OH NO! Are you okay?!
Wade: ARGH!
Wade: THIS IS THE WORST!
Ethan: DO IT, KILL HIM.
*Wade screaming and groaning*
Wade: OH GOD, WHAT ARE YOU AIMING FOR?!
*Wade cursing and groaning and screaming* [Wade: What NO!]
*Pleading for Bob's mercy*
*Laughter*
Mark: *singing* This is how we do it.
Wade: I THINK HE MEANT: "THIS IS HOW WE DO IT!" Oh.
*Laughter*
Ethan: Jesus Christ!
Ethan: Oooh that scared me.
Wade: You said chuck it over here!
*OOOOOH*
Ethan: OK SURE!
Mark: Tyler is a jerk.
*thunks are heard whenever the bottle lands on the table and small phrases can be heard from Mark, Ethan, and Bob*
Tyler: OOOH!
Mark: Hey, judge, was he over the line?
Ethan: Line judge wasn't paying attention.
Tyler: He was though.
Mark: He was over the line?
Tyler: The bottle was definitely over the line when he threw it.
Mark: OOOOOOOOH
Ethan: I mean...
Mark: Line judge HAS confirmed!
Mark: OOOOOOH.
*soft ohhh*
Mark: Do it! Do it!
Mark: 20 bucks that you don't make it.
Ethan: Am I still in line..?
Tyler: You just wanna win your 20 bucks back!
Mark: No, I won YOUR 20 bucks! I wanna win double or nothing!
Ethan: Am I still going?
Mark: Yes, you're going!
Ethan: Fuckin'...
Ethan: oioioioioioioi...
Wade: Still a chance Bob.
Bob: I mean, I still get to shoot even if he makes it.
Ethan: *voice crack* OH I mean! Who was watching yours?
Mark: That's what I wanted!
Ethan: I know!
Ethan: I think you should go again. Because no one was watching.
Ethan: You could've been right up the edge.
Mark: That's true.
Ethan: How do we know? How do we know?
Mark and Ethan: How do we know?
Tyler: Gimme that. *Ethan laughs*
Mark: 20 bucks you don't make it.
Tyler: I'm not making that bet.
Ethan: *Pinocchio impression* That was over the line! [Mark: That was over the line!]
Ethan:  You were like -this-!
Tyler: I was back here!
Ethan: Ehm, excuse me, you're don't get to go two times in a row!
Mark: No no, let him, let him, let's see.
Mark: It was clean.
Bob: His body was over the line.
Mark: *giggles* It was clean.
Wade: His body was over the line?
Tyler: WHAT? WHAT.
Mark: Wait, Ethan cut it that he missed it.
Mark: Cut out every single success that he had this whole video. Make it your success.
Mark: Wait, hang on, wait, Ethan, get up here. YEAH!
Ethan: YES!
Mark: YES!
Ethan: I DID IT!
Mark: ME TOO!
Ethan: DID YOU SEE THAT?! Wait *giggles*
Ethan: Wait, this should probably be on the table   *Laughter ensues*
Wade: Do this take again.  Mark: WHAT!!
Ethan: Why -
Mark: DUDE PERFECT!
Ethan: Is that your throw or my throw?
Mark (seriously): Mine.
Mark: ooooh~
Mark: loser!
Bob: do I get a chance to rebuttal or...
Ethan: Yeah, I think he should get a -
Mark: ...rebuttal. Yeah, okay rebuttal.
Wade: Wait that- that was never a thing-
Mark: Apparently it's a thing now.
Wade: It's a thing for Bob.
Bob: You just have to ask.
Mark: Yeah we're making this up.
Tyler: it's a reBOBble
Mark: Nope, okay, alright, let's shoot you with arrows.
Bob: Alright.
Bob: *muffled* I guess I lost
Bob:  *still slightly muffled* This is terrifying.
*Bobs screams and grunts*
Bob: That was hard!
Ethan: How does it feel to lose, Bob?
Bob: It does hurt more when you- when you get dick - AAH that's the face!
Mark: it's not the face
Bob: It's a face!
Mark: It looks like the face -
*Bobs terrified screams and grunts, laughter from the others*
Bob: it's so hard not to uncover!
*screams, grunts, laughter*
Mark: Ok alright, you did good Bob
Wade: I love the cringy eyes but I have the cringy eyes too
Mark: KOOOBY
Bob: wow.
*laughter*
Mark: So anyway thank you everybody so much for watching -
*Mark screams*
*laughter*
Mark: WHYYY?
Mark: That was the bottle flip challenge but we have more flipping action for you-
That we did on our own, that we're gonna show you guys.
Because we had a ton of fun just like, practicing and playin' around flipping stuff.
and...you know...
...the controlled setting...
Mark and Ethan: One...two...THREE
*THUNK*
*LAUGHTER*
Mark: So wasn't that fun? That was cool, okay-
Mark: So anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching
Mark: Thank you Bob, Wade, Tyler, whatever your name is-
Ethan (WhatEverYourNameIs): Thanks.
Mark: For joining us. And we really appreciate you all for watching! Hope you enjoyed it.
Mark: Anyway, see you in the next one. That's not my outro.
*LAUGH*
Mark: So that was fun. This is definitely not the third time we've done this outro.
Anyway, so thanks everybody so much for watching.
Thank you Bob, Tyler, Wade and Ethan for being here, all their links are in the description.
And let us know what you thought if you want to see something like this again in the future.
Let us know down in the comments below. Thanks again for watching.
And as always: we'll see YOU in the next video.
Buh-bye! (Various Byes)
[Jazzy Music]